The release of the Disney Plus series The
Mandalorian has brought with it one of the
most adorable creatures in the entire Star
Wars canon.
We are, of course, talking about Baby Yoda
whose tiny green frame and big floppy ears
have captured the hearts of fans around the
world.
"Stop touching things."
There are still plenty of questions surrounding
Baby Yoda, and Lucasfilm is keeping quiet
for now which, obviously, has only driven
Star Wars fans into more of a frenzy.
Just what is the child's significance to the
greater Star Wars universe?
What is its connection with the Yoda we know
and love?
And how powerful is this child?
Well, those questions might remain a mystery
for now, but in a recent interview with Esquire,
two-time Star Wars director J.J. Abrams offered
up a few suggestions as to why the character
exists in the first place.
Abrams explained:
"Star Wars is [...] ever-expanding.
And the ability to choose a character like
Yoda and say, 'What if we created a baby Yoda?'
— the reason these things are reasonable
to people is because it's not just nostalgia.
[...] It's taken something that is meaningful,
a story that has deep roots and potency and
resonates with a human heart, a beating heart."
Abrams went on to suggest that Baby Yoda's
appeal comes from far more than the creature's
cuteness.
He said:
"These are the kind of things that, when they
hit, [...] it's not just cute, but it implies
a story.
It sparks the imagination.
[...] All these things are about the possibility,
potential, and that's the very heart of what
Star Wars is."
With a universe like Star Wars, that has grown
so dramatically from the release of the first
film, there's always going to be room for
more more heroes, more villains, more lightsaber
battles, more evil dictatorships, and, of
course, more cuteness.
Abrams is clearly in favor of expanding the
Star Wars universe as much as possible and
the introduction of another of Yoda's species
is just one way of doing that.
Abrams told Esquire:
"I think that the fun of telling stories in
this galaxy is that you get to take things
that are familiar and you get to adjust them,
augment them, comment on them, continue them.
It's a world that is looking to be expanded."
Abrams also pointed out that the Star Wars
galaxy has always been bigger than it actually
seemed.
He said:
"The original movies did the most remarkable
thing in referencing the Clone Wars and the
Empire and the Senate, and the Old Wars, and
never showing any of these things.
[...] But you always felt that there was a
peripheral life and history and world beyond
what you were seeing."
But Abrams has kept quiet on whether or not
Baby Yoda's story could have an impact on
The Rise of Skywalker or whether the character
itself could even appear.
But regardless of whether or not The Child
shows up in the final chapter of the Skywalker
Saga, one question remains: could Baby Yoda
help establish the foundation for a new era
of Star Wars films?
George Lucas purposely left Yoda's origins
a mystery to Star Wars fans, making him the
only creature in the known galaxy whose species
is not explicitly named.
We know he isn't the only one of his kind,
because a female of the species, Master Yaddle,
appeared in The Phantom Menace but little
else is known about Yoda and his origins.
Having Baby Yoda feature in upcoming Star
Wars films could potentially clear up a few
mysteries about the tiny green Jedi Master,
from his species' origin to their apparent
natural strength with the Force.
It would also link the new era of Star Wars
to the old, and tie the small-screen universe
to the silver one.
Unfortunately, Abrams hasn't offered up any
theories as to how much information The Mandalorian
might reveal about Yoda's species.
But there's still a few episodes left of the
show to come and who knows how much deeper
the Star Wars galaxy might get?
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Star Wars
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.